ce que tu es charlie tout encore cinq
ans après non je me suis français mois
donc qu'est ce que tu veux dire pas à
partir du moment où il ya un attentat ou
une quelconque agression contre
quelqu'un qui est un concitoyen bas je
suis en deuil
c'est ça après je suis pas un homme de
slogan parce que je suis assez d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit jimmy je n'ai pas
manifesté tous les week-ends avec je
suis gilet jaune je suis charlie c'est
je mets pas ça sur le même niveau mais
la réalité c'est ce qui s'est passé il
ya maintenant cinq ans pardon de vous
dire ça mais si cinq ans après on est
encore ensemble à se demander qui est
charlie qui n'est pas charlie c'est
qu'il ya une erreur on est juste en
deuil
les musulmans comme les chrétiens comme
les juifs comme les athées ont tous été
traumatisée par le fait qu'on tue des
gens alors je suis bien d'accord qu'on
parle de charlie hebdo
j'ai aussi la tendresse et de
l'affection et de la tristesse pour
ahmed mera bête qui est un policier
musulman qui est mort à quelques mètres
de charal exactement s'aimer mais
au-delà de ça et aujourd'hui il s'avère
que 0 parle de la commémoration de la
tuerie de l'hyper cacher est ce qu'on va
me poser la question de savoir si je
suis hyper cacher ce qui s'est passé
pendant cette séquence de quelques jours
majus traumatisé point final que ce soit
l'hiver cacher charlie hebdo
c'est ce qui est assez intéressant c'est
marrant la notion de je suis charlie
c'est quand même des gens qui se veulent
agnostique et qui parlent de liberté
d'expression mais qui ont les mêmes
caractéristiques que les radicaux c'est
à dire que je suis charlie est devenue
une religion c'est à dire que si on est
contre c'est quasiment un blasphème
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure oui
aussi je dis moi par exemple je suis pas
charlie je vais pas le dire parce que ça
serait reprendre ce terme générique mais
je ne suis pas bien ça fait cinq ans
qu'on est là
quant à eux la manif je suis charlie je
vous invite à inviter à lire l'article
de magyd cherfi qui est le chanteur de
zebda et qui a écrit un livre magnifique
s'appelle ma part du gaulois qui est
venu comme moi à la manif je suis
charlie parce que moi je suis venue
manifester et les gens nous regardaient
en nous disant qu'ils sont les autres
musulmans mais moi je ne suis pas
représentants de six millions et demi de
personnes
chacun vient parce qu'il se sent
affectés ou pas après il s'avère que moi
je suis touché peut-être plus que la
norme sur les attentats de charlie je
suis français de confession musulmane et
il s'avère que je suis car éclate france
puisque je suis humoriste donc cette
notion de liberté d'expression que tout
le monde se trimballe je suis assez
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit moi je
trouve qu'ils ne sont pas marrant je
suis prêt à prendre un café avec riis
pour en parler en termes de collègues
mais après de là à faire la corrélation
comme ça peut être fait entre le fait de
dire je suis pas charlier je suis coup
achi
il ya une nuance entre les deux c'est ça
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que quand on dit je ne suis pas charlie
pour les gens aussi on est kwasi ah ben
non mais moi et en plus ça c'est marrant
dans votre montage alors je sais que les
choses se règlent jeudi les kwasi pour
moi ne sont pas des terroristes parce
que pour moi c'est des demeurés suite
voilà typiquement le genre de choses
ensuite pour vous dire charlie hebdo ne
marchait plus cher d'accord avec ce qu'a
dit eric naulleau ça ne marchait pas
factuellement il est allé à l'elysée
même demandé à françois hollande de les
aider sur un plan de sauvegarde donc ça
n'allait plus du tout le problème c'est
que ceux qui se réclament de l'esprit
charlie ne sont pas forcément les
dessinateurs concernés je vais vous dire
quelque chose
l'hystérie aller un tel point qu'on
acide sonner les cloches de notre dame
pour quelqu'un comme cabu qui était un
agnostique avéré c'est à dire que j'ai
beaucoup d'estimé pour charles qui a
disparu avec qui j'ai eu des discussions
même chez frédéric taddeï
on a été en débris on n'était pas
d'accord et moi j'ai le droit de dire ça
me fait pas marrer comme si quelqu'un va
au travail a dit ça me fait pas rire
mais c'est pas pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on
doit on arrive en bas s'ils disent pas
ça ça veut dire que quelque part ils
sont derrière eux les musulmans à la
base ne sont pas très lecteurs de
charlie parce qu'il s'avère que les
musulmans sont croyants et pratiquants
et que quand ils voient la liberté de la
somme qui a été citée tout à l'heure les
musulmans la respecte c'est juste que
avant charlie rester dans les kiosques
mais avec les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui on parle plus que de la
couverture de charlie et elle arrive aux
yeux des musulmans et les musulmans
réagissent en disant ça me fait pas rire
point final moi ce qui m'attriste c'est
que depuis cinq ans les musulmans n'ont
pas été conviés au deuil
ils n'ont pas été conviés au deuil de je
suis charlize ont pas pu venir exprimer
le fait qu' ils étaient eux aussi triste
parce que le slogan ne leur donnait pas
envie tout simplement de venir
je suis français je suis en deuil dans
les 38 % maintenant qu'ils disent mais
je ne suis pas charlie vous pensez c'est
pourquoi ces personnes ne sont pas
charlie penser que c'est ce que vous
venez dire parce qu'ils l'ont pas été
ils sont pas concernés sont pas invités
à le la vraie question c'est de savoir
que la communauté musulmane dieu merci
n'est pas une communauté homogène où
tout le monde se parle tout le temps
c'est à dire que déjà vous mettez deux
musulmans l'un face à l'autre ils vont
déjà se trouver comment ne pas
s'entendre et comment ne pas être
solidaires mais la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la communauté musulmane
il faut lui trouver des interlocuteurs
qui puisse dire oui ou non s'ils ne sont
pas d'accord
il s'avère qu'il ya pas de clergé chez
les musulmans dont vous pouvez inviter
les imams que vous voulez d'ailleurs la
télé a plutôt hâte alors pour trouver
des imams qui sont quand même
extraordinaire
eh bien ils vous diront tout simplement
que chacun choisit la manière dont il
est touché ou pas thaler j'entendais
cette prophétie
qui était génial et qui disait j'ai deux
élèves alors soit elle a des problèmes
dans toutes ses classes et à ce moment
là faut se remettre en question
personnellement mais aujourd'hui tous
les élèves qui se dit je suis pas
charlie va tout simplement il ya un vrai
travail de pédagogie à faire avec eux ce
qu'elle a essayé de fermer sans
soupçonner les parents moi je suis pas
sûr que quand j'étais un élève
si j'avais 15 ans lors des attentats de
charlie croyez moi qui assume belattar à
15 ans c'était pas super élevé d'un
point de vue moral et cérébrales et
heureusement qu'aujourd'hui je me
regarde avec dépit à 15 ans et que je me
pose la question de savoir pourquoi
aujourd'hui en tant que père de famille
ce qui s'est passé dans cette rédaction
tout autour m'a vraiment touché
énormément comme tous les français va
bien sûr